we brought updates that were free  to those who sail the sea though there's  always more potential within  and as this song will spell out there's  plenty to sing about  now that you can finally be a captain  can you imagine  owning your own ship  decorated with what you acquire  then to satisfy your vanity as long as  there's no profanity you can name it  just how you desire  oh  to  set sail as a pirate captain  there's loads of new features we  proclaim  or to set sail as a pirate captain  that's why we really think that you  should play this game and it's available  with xbox  [Music]  amazed gameplay what we have before the  choice is yours whatever captain you may  be whether that's cold blue teeth no  stop shooting global racing or embracing  everybody's welcome in this game  [Applause]  [Music]  our time is almost up so as we leave  if you want to be a pirate captain  come do it in season seven to see your  thieves  [Music]